i'm so flooded with everyone else's
opinions khloe kardashian is no stranger
to criticism but she
is defensive when it comes to boyfriend
tristan thompson
i'm really affected by what people have
to say in a new preview for keeping up
with the kardashians
chloe talks about receiving online hate
for getting back together with the nba
star
after he got caught cheating on her
chloe opened up about her insecurities
after scott disick left
this comment under one of her photos on
instagram
oh my god scott left a comment that
tristan is a lucky man honestly
me and tristan are figuring things out
but i'm still trying to navigate my way
through my
feelings and that's how i want to keep
it so i decided to delete scott's
comment just to
try to get rid of all this unnecessary
drama
last year et learned that chloe and
tristan have been working on rebuilding
their relationship
but even chloe admits that outside noise
from her peers can get to her head
i'm really affected by what people have
to say about my relationship like i'm
not even able to make up my own mind
because i'm so flooded with everyone
else's opinions or criticisms
it's like i don't even know what's
happening so why do
i have to be pressured to give people
answers that i don't have for myself
but scott and kim kardashian have a
different opinion about chloe's approach
there's gonna come a point where he
doesn't want to feel like you're
embarrassed of him still but it's still
got to be kind of hard
chloe has been a lot more open about her
relationship with tristan over the past
few months
earlier this month she posted this photo
with tristan and their two-year-old
daughter true for her 30th birthday
writing the ones that are meant to be
are the ones who go through everything
that is designed to tear them apart and
they come out even stronger than they
were before it's such a beautiful thing
a source tells et that the couple is
also wanting to expand their family and
that the kardashian jenners are fully on
board
quote as long as he continues to be a
great dad stays faithful
honest communicative and supportive they
all really enjoy tristan and consider
him family
true definitely wants a sibling too and
chloe and the rest of the family
want that for true too i think it's
gonna work i think it's gonna work
exactly
you know i've always wanted like four
kids so i have prince and true
two down two more to go okay well we'll
just have to see what
what happens chloe opened up to et about
co-parenting in 2019.
i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
my mom and my dad were like that it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be and
love is love